this topic has a reputation um and the
reputation is
it is boring and mechanical okay um
maybe not topic uh this concept this
process okay now that reputation
is justly deserved
because as you'll see we're going to
learn two methods for doing this
and both of them are quite mechanical
and repetitive okay
so what i'm going to try and do is
introduce these two methods
by drawing you back to like when did you
finish learning
i think it must have been about a year
ago when we were doing integration
a bit more than a bit less than a year
and we looked at not approximating roots
or solutions
but approximating areas now um two
colors here
you remember that when we learned
integration okay one of the cool things
was that
it seems kind of weird that when you
differentiate which is calculus in one
direction you get gradient
and when you integrate you go the other
way you get area and like gradient
area like they don't seem like they're
opposite to each other but we
established it mathematically we showed
that it was the case right
so if you want the area under the curve
you can say that
at least this area in particular is
given by a definite integral
okay so we connected uh calculations of
a geometric property
okay with this strange process so this
integral
here that would give us the area that
we're after
yes but as you're
familiar with not every function can be
integrated in fact
if you think about it like in the grand
scheme of things
most functions can't be integrated with
nice neat analytical methods
you just raise the power and do this and
divide and so on um
we sort of focus on the kinds of
functions that you can integrate
so it sort of feels like oh yeah i can
integrate like 90
of the stuff that's out there but if we
learnt more kinds of functions you'd be
like oh kind of degrade that or that or
that
there's all i can do and then the rest
of them you just can't touch them okay
but you can still work out the area
under the curve for
functions like that you just can't get
precision
okay so we learned two methods do you
remember what they were two methods for
getting
approximate areas under curves there was
the
the simplest one which was just taking a
polygon
and it was a trapezium right so we call
it trapezoidal rule
um so it was taking that and then you
know drawing however many subsections
and we know how to find out the area of
trapeziums that's fine
okay we also let another method a more
clever one
uh what was it called simpson's rule now
that's its name but
how did it work it wasn't using um a
trapezium or any other kind of polygon
what were we using to approximate the
curve
a parabola right which is actually when
you think about it
it's really smart you pick three points
and this is not a parabola okay
but if i pick three points on here
one two three you could draw a parabola
that was pretty close to it right that
would pass through all those points
i don't know something like this
okay so that could be a parabola and
you'd get really really close right
much closer than a trapezium okay so
these methods are actually
quite um they're quite thoughtful right
they're taking a problem which is
difficult
okay and they're not getting the exact
answer but they're getting pretty close
with some pretty smart tricks right
okay so there's there's these two right
now what's parallel to this
is when you think about if you're trying
to solve an equation
right find its roots okay so let's draw
a graph
and this time you don't have to draw
that but draw this with me okay
if you have say well okay quadratic
right for quadratic functions we know
how to find their roots in their
solutions
even if they're really weird gross
imaginary complex
we have a formula for it right but once
you step it up a little bit
okay if you have any polynomial or
higher degree
right um you're kind of stuck right the
cubic
formula which exists is terrible right
it's really really long
it's very awkward to use doesn't even
work in all the cases doesn't work for
all kinds of cubic functions
and if you raise the power it just gets
worse and worse and worse okay
so how do you find you know if there was
a root there
how would you do it okay now much the
same way as
you can find the exact route if you know
how to integrate and you can find an
exact route if you've got a particular
kind of function like a quadratic
we can't find the exact but we can get
pretty close
okay and just like with before there are
two methods okay
so i'm going to teach them to you and do
that one at a time so today
we're going to look at what's called the
bisection method
it's often also called halving the
interval i'll explain why in a second
well maybe you can tell me why
after i show you how it works
um which sort of like trapezoidal is
it's a very blunt tool
it's not very smart but it works because
it's not very smart it's a very slow
method
as you'll see shortly the second method
is smarter but it's more sophisticated
use calculus
and it's a it's a little more notorious
it's called newton's method
so since this rule needs method i don't
know what it is with people naming
you know rules after themselves but
that's what they are so
let's cover the bisection method today
right now on this graph that you've
drawn
i want you to imagine let's uh suppose
for this particular graph
okay we know that there's a root
somewhere
okay now the thing about these
continuous functions that's important by
the way
both of these methods they only work for
continuous functions do you have a think
as i am
as i explain them these two methods you
have to think about
why it wouldn't work if there was a
discontinuity okay
the thing about continuous functions is
that if you know
some value for the graph like say here
okay let's suppose that that's i don't
know um
let's call that one okay
when you test out this uh value if this
is f of x
okay if you put in one and you
substituted it
okay you would see that f of one
is negative okay so it's below the axis
that's geometrically what's
what it means okay and if you go further
along let's just say another value like
two
okay so if that's one two so something
like this
if you evaluate f 2 it's positive right
ok now if you're a continuous function
right
you can't change sign go from negative
to positive or
vice versa okay you can't change sign
without passing through the axis at some
point
okay see that's the that's why it's
important that it's continuous right
because if it was discontinuous it could
you know be negative here and then
disappear
have an asymptote or something like that
and then remain on the other side
okay but if it's continuous all the way
through if you go from negative to
positive
or positive to negative you've got to
have a root or a solution
in there somewhere okay so let's take
this example i need
my quadratic and let's go with it
here i'm going to say right f1 i i don't
need to know what this function is for
now okay just so that i can explain what
the method is okay
f1 is less than zero okay
but f2 is more than zero
okay therefore there exists
some f of now we want to actually have
some specific value okay so i'm just
going to call it x naught
uh there is some place where that's
equal to zero
right but not just that i know it has to
be between
one and two it's got to be somewhere
between these okay
such that
x naught is between these two values
okay
so if i notice between there right what
i can do is i can do a little more
testing
i tested two values here to get a little
more precision to kind of
narrow down where it is okay so this is
called the
bisection method right so i'm going to
try and get some more precision by
taking this interval right and
halving it so i'm going to test another
value now just on my diagram
just roughly speaking okay if i put 1.5
in there
okay i can see in this case that f of
1.5
is up here okay so
i test
f of 1.5 and i find it's positive
okay so what does this mean well if f1
is negative
and f2 is positive from here here 1.5 to
2
it's still positive so the solution is
not in there right
it's going to be somewhere in this
little interval
right so i can continue going i can go
from 1 to 1.5
halfway is 1.25 right
someone test again
now at least on my diagram 1.25 looks
like it's the actual group okay so
my diagram is going to not be very
helpful here but just suppose
okay suppose that it was just beneath
the axis
okay now what does that tell you um that
means that the root must be between
1.25 and 1.5 see how there's a change of
sign
right so there's my 1.25
just to the left okay so i don't know
what the exact value is i'll get some
decimal out when i evaluate
the function what would you find but i'm
going to get closer and closer and
closer
right so for instance at this point i
can say
if i want to say the one decimal point
okay i can say it's either 1.3 or 1.4
right so if i halve the interval again
if i bisect again i know i'm going to be
closer to one on the other
and then i can say after three
repetitions of this method
i can say oh it's going to be
approximately 1.3 or approximately 1.4
whichever it turns out okay so does that
make sense can you see the mechanic
behind how it works
you can also see why people find it
quite boring and
kind of cool okay but it's quite clever
when you think about it in terms of like
how else would i solve this problem
okay bisection method
it's very mechanical and it's very
simple okay but despite the fact that
you can do it quite
mindlessly when you're going through all
the steps okay you can't just pick
things blindly and just and just go for
it what i mean is uh these two values
you start out with like these two
okay you have to be careful when you
choose them okay and then the obvious
example
is when you've got multiple roots that
are close together okay so suppose
i don't know my scale's a bit off but
suppose that was one and that was two
okay just yeah bad scale but you get the
idea okay obviously here
you'll see when you test f1 you'll get a
negative
and when you test f2 you'll get a
positive okay
but all the bisection method will do is
establish
that there must be one solution between
those change of signs
okay so the first thing is you're going
to omit solutions
like you know uh you might eventually
only wind up at one of them
okay but uh depending on how they go
but anyway you'll miss some solutions
okay you'll miss a pair
but secondly when you actually start to
test out values they'll go all over the
place
because there are more changes of sign
in there than just the
simple one that you can tell now i'm on
the left now i'm on the right and so on
okay so make sure you actually pick out
if they don't tell you
right where they don't give you a
vicinity you have to be very careful
when you actually pick your values to
make sure
that you only got one solution and
you'll see the same kind of problem
picking your value carefully that
applies to newton's method as well
okay so just make sure you have a note
of that that you have this kind of
diagram
and you make sure to avoid having
multiple routes between
your two testing points okay and that's
basically all there is to the dissection
method
okay i reckon probably you can pack up